That's why I want you to prove that if you show your bra, you're
not lucky. Mika, I don't have a smartwatch,
but I want you to
measure your heart rate when you look at each bra and see how excited you are.
So I can see your bra naturally.
I don't think so, but even if there's something else, let's go ahead and see it.
[Music] Let's take a look.
These are Milica's breasts.
186 Hoshizaki-san is
so big and so excited. And I'm sure there's only two people in front of you.  In that case, I
wish you
all the best in your life. That's what I'm looking for. It's the cutest thing in your bra. In other words,
this is Se-san's game. Shige. Are you
really allowed to look at something so important? No,
yes,
thank you.  You're welcome
Everyone, after I've
been able to prove how much I love Se-san,
even if I win against Milica, I'd hate it if I lost to Chan, and
I love both of them equally, so theoretically they
should be the same number, right?
But I've chosen my favorite one.If it's a
pack, I'll prove it to you.It has a
plain, everyday feel, but it's different from Se-san's
cute bra, and above all, it
has a freshness that Saki-chan has been wearing up until this very moment.  It was so overwhelmingly vivid that I felt like I could feel the
warmth and scent of Saki-chan.It
was true.I thought we should
go out.Let's go
fishing.How
fast will my heart rate be
?  wax